my name is John Austin and I'm an
independent game developer and so I'm
here to talk about color so let's set
the scene a little bit just to get
started the year is 1931 and that means
a couple of things are true math has
gone on slide rules so it's barely the
concept of you know electrical computing
you know electricity is still coming to
rural parts of America like there's this
big push to electrify the rural America
30 percent of homes are still without
power and on top of that at this time
the stock market had just crashed and
this was you know the biggest depression
in US history but also worldwide like 16
percent of the entire world was without
work 25 percent in the US and so you
know in the midst of all of this a bunch
of people decided that you know this
would be a good time to get together and
and come up with like a unified standard
of color and so a bunch of people met in
this dusty room in in France and and
sort of decided to come up with the
systems that actually underlie and all
the systems that we use today for RGB
and the color that we use even into it
like kind of the digital era and it's
sort of a testament to sort of the the
depressions of the work they did there
that it still lasts all the way to
nearly a hundred years later you know
and in today's world the color is just
everywhere right it's in it's in our
images it's in like the web it's in our
books it's in our clothing right when
when you want to go make a new you know
a piece of clothing you need to know
what color to diet right somebody has to
tell you what color to make and you know
in this crazy world of color who must
have these fantastically complex system
is to manage you know that the powerful
nature of it but you know most of us
probably just you know eyeball the
sliders and so it looks about right but
you know what actually is RGB right like
what is a hundred red like most people
don't really have a good concept of it
and so you know what I want to talk
about today is it's kind of the history
of color you know how is it made and how
these
made and then also the science of it
like what are the things we're actually
using today and how can we you know work
backwards and follow the lineage back to
the systems that were created in the
1930s you know color is this like crazy
weird subject because it's inherently
subjective right it's like you know what
is art and what is beauty and like color
perception right but it's also you know
insanely objective it's you know
wavelengths it's light you can measure
it you know and sort of in the midst of
all of this there's color systems I try
to represent it and so I've been ever
since I learned about this stuff I've
been excited to give a talk on it
because it's just every time you peel
back a layer you get something more and
you learn something new about how we
perceive the world so it's just super
cool and so that's what this talk is
gonna be about so to start with let's
look a little bit of biology so you can
think of light as a pipeline so you know
light bounces around the world it hits
your eye bounces around inside there
hits a few sensors and then goes to your
brain and so we can look at each of
these kind of components individually so
light is a spectrum it's what we can see
visibly is a fairly small part of the
spectrum right so that's that on the
left there is the spectrum of the Sun
and most of the light that's put out by
the Sun is not visible to us at all
right now it's either in the ultraviolet
or infrared zones and so this like
little chunk of visible light is sort of
just biological happenstance like
there's nothing particularly objective
about the visible spectrum it's just the
way we're set up to see and in fact you
know heat for instance like everything
that is hot gives off light in form of
radiation right and so that's why you
can hold up a camera and see you know an
infrared picture of a heat signature
because it's it's light in some respect
right so if we were built a little bit
differently like say we were a bee or
like you know some other animal we would
see just different parts of the spectrum
you know and so light isn't necessarily
quite as you know light and color aren't
is objective as it might seem at first
and so you know we have this spectrum
right and it goes into our eye and it
hits these things called cones
and the cones are our sensors in our
eyes that are primarily responsible for
our color perception we saw we have
three types of cones now we have our
short cones the medium cones and long
cones and each of these cones responds
to a different part of the spectrum and
you know you can sort of already see
something interesting here which is that
these cones kind of align to red green
and blue to some degree you know it's
not perfect but you can think about why
we might use these colors as our basis
for you know color definition because
they nicely spaced along the spectrum
right it gives us a lot of resolution in
that way and it's kind of weird too it's
like well look at our green cone is
really heavily overlapping on the red
cone right and we can think about how
that might like add some weirdness to
the way that we perceive colors around
those zones right so we have these three
cones and basically each cone ends up
kind of producing a number so if you're
looking at this you know let's say
you're looking at an apple and you're
looking at maybe this that little pixel
right you know like the two-degree
you know part of the your vision that is
seeing that color each of your cones is
going to respond in a different way and
so you kind of get these three numbers
that are sent to the brain and and you
can sort of measure these and you can
actually put units on them but but
they're more like brain units they're
not you know especially the 1930s they
weren't about to measure these but you
know now we can with modern technology
but the interesting part about this
setup is that we can actually describe
all color that we can see was just three
numbers which it shouldn't be inherently
intuitive to you right like light is
this crazy spectrum all these numbers
and different types of waves and but you
know you only need three numbers to
describe every single visible color that
you can see and this is why all of our
color systems use three numbers because
that's all you really need at the base
level so you know this you know then
also brings up an interesting question
which is like well what if you have two
spectrums and maybe they're wildly
different but they map to the same color
right because this is a lossy operation
there's way more spectrums and there are
you know three digit numbers and so this
is what's called a metamer
and so these are all around us all the
time so you might think that you know
the green of the grass and the green of
a lime the green of tea is you know all
the same color but in reality these are
wildly different spectrums it just
happens to be that you perceive them as
the same color and in fact this is how
modern display technology works right
it's all about how do you tickle those
cones just well enough to pretend that
you're seeing the right color right
they're not actually trying to recreate
the spectrum on the monitor they're just
trying to make you think that you're
seeing the colors so we can think about
you know other animals that you know
might be set up differently so like the
humble pigeon
he is a penta Chrome App so he has five
cones and you know when the pigeon looks
at colors in the world you might see
totally different colors right again
it's this like sort of biological
happenstance right so like color is
pretty weird right it it seems objective
at the start but the way we describe
color might end up needing to be a
little bit more brain length than we
might think and being able to talk about
colors is you know it's important right
like even in the 1930s this was
important and like you know we need some
way to say even though it's all this
kind of in your head right we need some
way to be like oh hey now this is the
color I'm talking about and you know
back then the main concern they had you
know they didn't have monitors right but
you know they had signal lights on
planes and boats and so like you know as
the world became more globalized you
know it became important to you know
know what colors are on different ships
right like if you tell your ally that
you know you have green on the left and
red on the right like you best be sure
that you know what green and red you're
talking about so that you can you know
communicate properly so you know this
seems kind of trivial but this actually
drove a lot of the the color science
research that defines all the systems we
use today and so enter the CIE 1931
International Commission on lighting and
so this was basically a big convention
with a bunch of different countries and
sort of the plan was like a we're all
going to get together and we're going to
vote on a specification that defines a
standard for color and then you know
they had sent out this specification
ahead of time because
is now back in that time communication
was hard and tiring and so they needed
some time to kind of look over stuff and
sort of the two big heavyweights in this
convention were Britain in the US and
they had been doing most of the
colorscience for the past decade or so
and one of the big players from England
was a man named John Gill and he worked
at the National Physical Laboratory
there and John Gill was pretty excited
because it was his system that was to be
voted on at this conference he had come
up with this system of additive
primaries which is just to say that you
can you know you can add colors together
and you get new colors and it's kind of
abstract you know I didn't really
represent a closed system to the way
that humans think about color but how
these mathematical properties that were
really nice and the an so this is this
is the system they were going to be
voting on and so there was another man
at the conference and his name was Irwin
priest so urban priest was the
representative from the United States he
was the president of the optical society
for America and you know when our urban
priests got off the boat he was mad he
was livid and it might have been for
good reason I mean I mentioned that they
sent out those you know resolutions
ahead of time but they had really only
sent them out about a month in advance
and like that wasn't nearly enough time
to actually study them or do the the
rigorous kind of scientific research to
actually you know judge them so they
could vote on them so here's a little
mist by that you know but the other
thing was that the u.s. actually already
had a system of color so they already
had a standardized system and they had
adopted this system a few years earlier
and and the u.s. systems was not based
on this additive primary stuff it was
based on something a little more
pragmatic because it was driven by
industry so you know it was basically
based on you know these things
huge saturation and brightness with
different names and you know we might
recognize that from today and we can
think of like what why do we use that in
our color pickers because it's no it's
inherently kind of just a very pragmatic
way about you know reasoning about color
so he was angry he was ready to fight so
what did he do well he you know arranged
for himself to arrive a week early
so that he and John guild could you know
have a talk before the conference and
you know over the course of an
exhaustive week you know they kind of
went back and forth debating their
different systems and you know one of
the cool things about John guild system
is you know even though it wasn't very
pragmatic it had this property that it
could be transformed to other systems so
because it had these mathematics you
know he basically showed how it should
represent priestess systems so he slowly
transformed it to priests system to show
how it's a better standard even if it's
not as pragmatic and then so basically
over the course of the week they they
settled on you know a final set of
systems and so they scrapped the
original systems of their sent out you
know much to the other country of
chagrin and so they presented you know a
new set of resolutions called the CIE
1931 resolution Sun color and so you
know these are the systems that we use
in a lot of ways that define like all of
our color spaces that we use or at least
the you know the fundamental bits of it
so the question remains you know like
well okay what are these color
resolutions right you know and like you
know what is RGB and like what is the
color space like what are all these
things so that's kind of what we'll
spend the rest of the talk doing so like
we'll go a little bit through the
science of it and kind of explain it
what are these systems and we'll work
our way all the way back to where we are
today in the present it's not it's not
too much don't worry all right so let's
go back to John guild system so at the
end of the day it was basically his
system that was accepted with some
modifications and his system was based
on this concept of additive primaries so
you're back in the day you couldn't
measure color okay so if you wanted to
actually measure the spectrum you'd need
a spectrophotometer and that hadn't been
invented yet so they had to be a little
more creative and so he came up with
this experiment where you you put the
target color on the Left say this kind
of green color and you know yeah well
yes let's say you have this target green
color and you place three colors
the right that you do know the
wavelengths for maybe you can prove this
through physics or through some other
means and then you sort of add and
subtract them until you make up the
color on the left and so that kind of
gives you three numbers right it gives
you how much of each of those primaries
did you need to make up that color and
so you know he did this with a bunch of
different colors and if you plot those
in a three dimensional space with each
axis being kind of you know the amount
of that color then you get this volume
of color and this you know inherently
this is a color space it's a space with
a bunch of colors in it and that's
basically the most general definition a
color volume is another word for it
right and the interesting thing about a
color space is that you can do math in
this color space which also should not
be very intuitive at all because you
know color is this crazy spectrum but as
it turns out you can take the three
numbers from this color space that John
Gill is working on and you could add
them together and the color you got as a
result would be the same color you'd get
as you would in real life if you would
new overlaid those lights and so this
property which is like kind of amazing
is like the fundamental basis of how we
use code it's the reason we can do math
on color at all which you know isn't
necessarily a given and so they were
they were realizing this at the time and
so you know that's how they put together
these these early color spaces so he
sort of said about making this this
first color space right and mapping out
the visible colors but you know he came
up with this problem and it's easiest to
describe this problem if we go back into
2d we do this a lot in color science
because reasoning about volumes and
showing them is really hard you can't
look inside them easily you need to
render them it's a total pain so a lot
of a lot of time we project it down into
a 2d 2d space so if this is all the
visible colors that we can see right and
you know we're John Gill then we've
picked three primaries maybe we've put
them here you know right on the edges of
visible color then all the colors we can
make are inside of this triangle because
those are the colors that can be blended
between those three primaries and so the
realization here is that you can't
actually recreate all visible colors
with a fixed set of primaries and you
know that should make you think well
that also means that today right if you
have a monitor you can't actually make a
monitor that can represent all visible
colors it's impossible if you if you
just use a fixed set of primaries you
know in fact if you have sixty five
hundred dollars to burn in your pocket
you can go buy a laser TV that has like
no less than six laser primaries and it
gets you pretty pretty dang close but
it's still you still you know you're
only inching your way to covering this
volume so you know he realized this at
the time and so in order to map out the
space he needs to be a little more
creative let's say you have this cyan
color and so some of these colors are
gonna know the color space of this
display is limited the projector is so
you'll have to imagine some of this but
I think it should work for the most part
so let's imagine you have this cyan
color that you can't make with these
other two primaries what you can do
instead is you can add a color on the
other side and sort of treat it like a
negative color and you know what if you
do that then you actually can make those
colors equal and so by using this sort
of negative trick he was able to map out
the full color space and what he created
was something called CIE RGB and this is
the first color space it's sort of the
granddaddy of all historical color
spaces and it's different than the RGB
you're thinking of this is CIE RGB and
it you know just happens to also use red
green and blue as the primaries and you
can sort of see you know here there's
the negative colors hanging off the back
there but you know roll is really cool
about this is now we have a way that we
can talk about colors you know you can
the Navy can come to you and be like you
know we need some color for our colored
glass and they'll be like oh that's a
negative two point seven point six and
you know you know what you're talking
about it's you can go look it up and
what you can do is you can you know take
that number and transform it you know
back to the spectrum you can sort of use
a scientific process to kind of test
your glass until you know that it's
recreating the color you want and so
this is a you know this is a big
invention right like now we can finally
reason about color in a very objective
way but you know this color space it's
got a lot of problems right is negatives
are super weird right like what is a
negative red anyway and like you're
doing math on slide rules like negatives
are awful and you know this is one of
the big you know the big criticisms of
priests too and you know what are the
boundaries of this right like it's sort
of based on this experimental
methodology it's not that great and so
what they realized is they needed to
make a more ergonomic color space and
you know we talked about how color
spaces can be transformed like that's
the big property of color spaces and so
what we can do is what was transform
this color space into something more
mathematically ergonomic let's just
stretch it and squish it into something
better so and then you know here's
here's a big point about these
transformations is that they have to be
linear and basically all linear means is
that the origin has to stay in the same
spot and lines have to stay straight an
easy way to check to see if your
transformation is linear is can it fit
in a three by three matrix if you can
it's linear you're all good otherwise
you can't yeah and so it's important
that you need this linearity property in
order to get that mathematical behavior
we talked about right as long as your
transformation is linear then addition
and subtraction in that new color space
will still recreate the properties of
real life and so this is like this is
the property we want so you know they
said about making this new ergonomic
mathematical color space and you know
again they were kind of clever they
realized that well okay you know
previously our visible our primaries
were in the visible color space but you
know if we choose our primaries to be
imaginary then we can stretch our color
space to be entirely positive and you
know this is super weird it's like only
mathematical right like you can't
represent these colors at all in real
life
and so they called it XYZ because well
these primary these axes don't have any
meaning anymore so they were like always
: XYZ and XYZ is great like it's it's
mathematically beautiful everything's
positive it's all less than one
they put white at one third you know one
thing they did as well and here's like a
3d sort of representation they aligned
the y-axis with brightness so if you
want to know how bright a color is you
just have to look at the second value
super easy and so you know CIE XYZ this
is you know you know nobody really talks
about you know all these other color
spaces before CIE XYZ like XYZ is kind
of like the main the main player in
today's world if you want to make a new
color space let's say your Adobe you
would provide a transformation back to
CIE XYZ you you know you can go on
Wikipedia and you can find the three by
three matrices that gets you back to CIE
XYZ for all your favorite color spaces
and in doing so that sort of proves that
it's you know a valid color space that
it represents all the simple colors and
that you can transform between them
right so flashing forward to 2019 you
know now we're in the digital world
right so that's sort of the end of right
30s you know with CIE XYZ but now you
know colors everywhere like we have all
these other concerns about monitors and
displays and images and computing and
and so in the seventies they realized
that they needed you know a color space
I was really built for the digital world
and this color space is called srgb and
this is the color space that you've been
waiting for this is like the standard
RGB and so when you use that color
picker in Chrome or you know Photoshop
it's in in srgb that's the color space
of the values you're specifying and it's
easiest to show srgb it's a color space
like all the others but we usually we
show them against X Y Z X Y Z is this
sort of like for father of of color
spaces we can we kind of compare them so
if we show the 2d you know visible gamut
of CIE XYZ we can say that okay srgb is
a subset of it
and we know it has to be a subset
because you know our monitors use
visible primaries right you know you
have to the corners of a triangle have
to be visible colors so you know has to
be a subset but it's a particularly
small subset to which you know you might
wonder why that is I mean it was
originally designed for CRT monitors and
CRT displays couldn't show anything more
than that so why would you waste the
bits so we can also show that in this in
3d as well against kind of CIE XYZ and
you can see that it's not you know it's
not a triangle right it's it's really
this three dimensional prism shape but
it's a lot thinner right it's missing a
lot of these these more interesting
colors you know an interesting to note
about this right is you're looking at
this right now in srgb right this
display uses srgb so this entire
presentation has been compressed right
down into it's been projected and
there's all sorts of transformations you
can use to protect it but it what you're
seeing right now is yeah it's like a
relative like you know
judgment of these color spaces so those
greens you know that seem to be missing
you know you can't see them anyway so
anyway so srgb like the others is just
one more transformation so it's you get
this kind of mathematical lineage coming
so you know srgb it's kind of this
universal transfer format right
everything uses it but it's got this
weird quirk and it's easiest to explain
it if we talk about kind of human
perception so when you look at let's say
let's say I go linearly increasing
brightness of color we're much better at
telling the difference between darker
colors than brighter colors the white
the big bright whites kind of wash out
to us whereas we could find a lot of
subtleties in in the darker colors
relatively speaking and so they realized
this in the 70s and they decided well in
that case why don't we not spread our
bits uniformly we'll you know put more
bits down that the part we can tell the
difference between which makes a lot of
sense right if you're really bit limited
you know
it's important that you spend those
really on the parts that make that are
most important and so what they did is
they well okay with this 3x3 matrix they
also applied this extra operation which
is called the gamma curve and it's
essentially a square root it's you know
it's a piecewise it's not exactly a
square root but generally you can call
it a square root you can look it up on
Wikipedia but essentially what this
curve does is you know spread out the
color space such that it's kind of a
little more optimal for storage you know
but the weird thing about this extra
transformation is that it's not linear
and we made this big fuss about you know
how we want our transformations to be
linear so that we have so the math works
in the new color spaces and and so that
what actually ends up happening is that
you know math in srgb is not correct and
so what that means is that if you add
two colors in srgb like the color space
you use every day you won't get the
color you would get if you add them in a
real life and so this is sort of like
the perpetual problem of like incredible
amounts of software if you take away
like one thing from this talk it's that
you probably shouldn't be doing math and
srgb I converted to some other color
space any other color space basically
but you know srgb is still important
because it's a universal transfer format
and you know it's got great bit density
and stuff like that but you know like
you might think that maybe this isn't a
big deal that much but so like let's
look an example
so back in 2010 most game rendering at
that time was being done in srgb
directly because you know that was the
color space they were using they didn't
really have the performance to think
about it too much and what you get is
you get all of your light being thrown
through this exponential function and so
like your whites get crunched and your
darks get crunched and it looks really
awful and so you know after 2010 they
started doing physical physically based
rendering and everything looks much
better because what they did was they
used a linear color space
and you know generally what most game
engines use nowadays is something called
linear srgb which is essentially to say
it's srgb but they don't do that you
know extra gamma curve they don't do the
square root of this drop lap so then
they keep the whole transformation
linear and that makes it a linear color
space so everything's good and then you
get these much better colors okay so
we've we've got our we've got our 92
main color spaces now we've got like
srgb that's what you use but you know if
you want to do math on it you should
probably be using something linear but
it's not quite the end of the picture
you know there's lots of times where
maybe we don't want scientific accuracy
right like this has all been about
recreating the properties of real life
we've been trying to you know find color
spaces that lets you you know
yeah recreate these behaviors of like
overlaying lights in the real world but
you know sometimes you want to do
something like more artistic you care
more about perception so let's look at
an example so this is a constant
brightness slice of you know the srgb
spectrum and what that means is that the
intensity of the wavelengths of light
that are leaving the screen going to
your eye are all equal or at least the
projector is doing its darndest to try
to make it equal and what you can notice
about this is that these colors don't
look perceptually equal in their
brightness we have this tendency to
perceive yellow as especially as
particularly bright compared to you know
corresponding blues and same with whites
and so our color perception is not
perceptually smooth you know and so
let's look at another color space so
there's this color space called CIE lab
and CIE lab is a color space that's
built to spread it out such that the
color space is fully perceptually
uniform and so what you get is this
incredible like smooth gradient of you
know what looks actually perceptually
uniform and the wheat you know the weird
thing about CIE lab is that CIE lab
intentionally does these non
linear operation so it's no longer a
curatorial life but it does them
intentionally such that when you do math
and CIE lab it makes something that
looks more perceptually correct which i
think is really cool like CAE lab
totally blows my mind like there are a
few things that you can do where you can
just drop something into your project
and all of a sudden it looks ten times
better
CIE lab is basically the secret gem of
the data visualization community like
d3.js all these people because all of
these you know visualizations are driven
by data and math right and so they want
these crazy nice linear gradients right
but if you do a gradient in RGB you get
this kind of dark spot in the middle
it's a little easier to see if you
squint sometimes the projectors a little
rough but basically if you try to
interpolate the RGB that the color space
wasn't built for interpolating it was
built format like adding and subtracting
and see sometimes you can get these
weird hues that just pop out of nowhere
but lab was built for you know uniform
this and so it's it's when you
interpolate through lab you get these
great gradients yeah so this is like
really what power is that it is and like
you know let's look at one more example
of lab just because I think it's so cool
so you know you might think this is a
pretty trivial operation like we want it
let's say we want to desaturate a an
image right just make it grayscale and
so we take this painting of a sunflower
right and you know it might look pretty
similar look at that sunflower right so
we've we've gray scaled it in RGB at the
top in linear RGB so this would be
correct - real light right but that
sunflower is super dark compared to lab
and we can sort of zoom in just to
emphasize that point like look how much
worse it looks and one thing you can
kind of note is like on the edges of
those petals there there's these like
little white spots and those white spots
aren't really present on the original
image it just so happens that these like
two hues you work out such that you know
the actual intensity of light is like
really different but to our brains we
see them as very perceptually similar
and so when you're - in greyscale like
it might seem like a super simple
operation but it's actually a perceptual
operation right we want to know what
looks like
the brightness of each pixel and so we
should do that generally in lab and so I
would suggest that if you know you're
doing some math on color that you you
know think a little bit about which
color space you might want to use I
prepared a little bit of a table just to
kind of help with that and these slides
will be up online later probably too but
you know if you care about science and
rendering and you really want to create
you know correct to life light right
then you want to use linear color you
can use linear srgb there's lots of
other linear color spaces but if you
care about perceptual correctness right
and you want something that's smooth and
uniform CIU lab is definitely something
interesting to reach for I definitely
recommend trying it out and of course we
have to use srgb because everything
expects that's RGB our monitors expected
the web expects it
so advantage day we still have to use it
but we should probably get it out of
srgb as soon as possible
I mean like for instance like well you
know new MacBooks right they have better
monitors like part of the reason they
they look nicer is because they render a
bigger subset of the visible spectrum
but of course that means if you're
sending srgb to your macro box you're
not taking advantage of that nice you
know spectrum that it can render so you
know you should think about even if you
are you know just rendering something to
a display device like what display
device is that and maybe you should use
a different color space that you can
take advantage of those properties so
that's about it thanks for the for
listening you can follow me on Twitter
I'd post about all sorts of crazy games
and art and math and whatnot quick
thanks to the CIE which is apparently
still around and kicking and helped me
like come up with some primary sources
and track down some articles from the
original conferences but yeah I have
absolutely no clue if I of extra time
five minutes I could take some questions
yeah if you have them and then otherwise
I'll just be outside yeah
right so CIE lab is so you can see up
there on the top or right that is that's
the visible visible gamut of all colors
in CIE lab so it does represent all
visible colors so one of the downsides
of CIE lab is that it's not a subset but
that means you need floating-point
numbers so so CIU lab is not an additive
primary system it's based on three
numbers it's based on lightness and then
a and B and where a and B are basically
like the color but because it's not
based on additive primaries they don't
have that restriction where it has to be
like you know just a subset of the
visible spectrum and so they'd it's more
a lot more like XYZ in that sense it's
also it's also a little weird cuz lab by
default it's not in the range 0 to 1
it's zero to a hundred for some
reasonable reason but but yeah I can
represent all visible colors yeah
right yeah
so the question is you know when you're
looking at these 3d volumes like what
does that really mean what like what is
the reasoning behind that
so yeah you're looking at this
essentially the surface and the reason
we do so much in 2d is because these 2d
slices this is because yeah you can't
see into this volume right yeah like
really it's basically like a you could
take a slice throughout the entire thing
like a cross-section and you'd see you
know different colors changing and so
like it's a volume not a surface so
there's colors inside of it yeah that is
a serious question
that's a good question yeah man I would
I would have loved to talk about print
because there's so much there like
there's all sorts of crazy different
color spaces I had to leave a lot off
for time concerns so print is based on
something called CMYK and so that's four
numbers which is odd but print is unique
because it's it's a lot more driven by
the sort of material science and like
the actual process of making and
printing things out than it is by trying
to represent colors mathematically so
CMYK is you know cyan magenta yellow and
black technically it stands for key
which is like an old term but yeah
anyway I so CMYK is also weird because
it's device dependent so like all these
color spaces we've been talking about a
single color represents a single color
like that's it's just that's what it is
that's the color but CMYK it depends on
what printer you're talking about what
kind of ink you're talking about so like
you might have you know CMYK this number
but it only represents a certain color
if you know what ink you're talking
about and you know and if you change the
paper everything changes because the
reflectance changes CMYK is also
subtractive which is a little weird in
the sense that it's see it's CMYK
because cyan represents the removal of
red right so if you add cyan that's like
moving red and so millat of messiness in
there it's also you know dotted like
it's actually has what these what's
called hash toning which is kind of like
what comic books use where they it's
kind of dot everything to sort of blend
the colors in your head it's I would
definitely will I take more questions
afterwards if we could talk a lot about
printing but I yeah yeah it's very
interesting sure it's because they're
bad monitors yeah
this is why people who you know work
doing art for a living care a lot about
getting a really nice monitor because
wrap it okay so it's the last question I
guess so yeah like um yeah not all
monitors are made equal so like we
talked about like you have this RGB
color space and you know you want to go
back and map that back to the spectrum
right but that's really hard
transformation it's like okay how do I
get these LED lights to like get the
right colors and tickle your cones in
the right ways and so you know cheaper
monitors just do a worse job at it and
you can actually buy something called a
spider which will sit on top of the
monitor analyze it and then recalibrate
your monitor to the best it can which I
don't know if I'd recommend for everyone
but if you really care about color that
might be something to do okay well I
mean I'll definitely take more questions
outside but thanks for coming
[Applause]